t'inquiète qui a été fait sur les
médecines qui attire le plus les femmes
et les métiers qui attire le plus les
hommes alors que les femmes sont
attirées par les pilotes de ligne par
les entrepreneurs par les pompiers par
les docteurs et en 5 par les
journalistes et personnalités de la baie
verte renouvelle les hommes sont attirés
par les kinésithérapeutes un nom en a
besoin
oui les architectes d'intérieur les
entrepreneurs les chargés de
communication et enfin les enseignantes
alors vous parlions à quel métier vous
êtes attirés je parle bien sûr
sexuellement parlant je suis mariée avec
un pompier alors ça fait le fantasme
absolu il a le plus avec le petit réseau
de pipelines liseré rouge jeux les jeux
les rencontrer à djibouti on était en
voyage de plongée et lui il était là bas
et quand on est revenu sur paris il m'a
invité à boire un verre et je suis allé
le voir et ils étaient en tenue
militaire à m puis voilà
il vous a montré sa caserne j'ai alors
j'ai pas osé la sphère la santé vous
allez tomber dessus est toujours élégant
alors vous en avant tel c'est qu'est-ce
que vous et moi mon rêve était d'abord
j'ai démarré un carré en temps de crise
y est mais mon rêve saisir des gens je
rêvais d'être gynécologue faisait pas
demandé qui était votre métier mais par
quel métier vous étiez rien comme
c'était rien confirmé qu'en dehors
commandant de bord et fantasmé elle
aurait quel métier à la personne qui me
ferait fantasmer les actrices menace
mais parce qu'elles ont besoin d'être
protégés et on vous êtes sur six réseaux
non
si abbas immochan je vous ai vus ont une
âme et on va rater deux secondes vous
été en une d'un magazine et qu'une
actrice américaine
absolument oui
elle était encore pas mal à cette époque
là elle était très belle et je sais
comment ça s'est passé alors dit oui
c'était l'histoire c'est un coup non
c'est un coup médiatique je veux dire
oui dans l'histoire elle était tout
simple on s'est rencontré à saint tropez
ça s'est très bien passé classique pour
vous saint-tropez travailler je
travaillais à saint tropez à ce moment
là j'avais une radio et sur la place des
lices où je recevais plein d'artistes et
on a beaucoup sympathisé gelé présenter
tout le monde on a dîné chez johnny chez
juliette gréco g et le reste voilà bah
vrai bien et donc il ya eu il ya une
connexion
il ya une grande connexion très bien
écouter et nous sommes restés très amis
daniel moreau alors qu'elle éleva dans
votre cas simplement parce qu'il faudra
faire pour une personne mais c'est du
temps gagné une personne il faudrait
qu'elle est quel métier un peu comme
natacha j'aime que les gens aiment les
militaires la musique l'album et surtout
surtout les marins les marins parce que
ça porte bonheur à cause du ch croyez
moi j'en ai fait du tout cette pompe
dans ma chienne de vie
[Rires]
hier
wima dirait peu importe le médium c'est
ce qui est bien avec les militaires
c'est qu'ils repassent ils font de
repassage passé avant même de repasser
alors pour mission les applications de
rencontre je suis attiré par les
musiciennes et chanteuses à nous regarde
ça marche et je suis sorti quatre ans
avec une musicienne la contrebasse de
hockey ensuite la contrebasse c'est
nicolas oui quel métier de femme debout
fait fantasmer je sais pas je dirais
plutôt hôtesse de l'air c'est vraiment
le fantasme par excellence ah oui est ce
que vous savez c'est l'eau et c'est le
fantasme arts excellence est en fait une
psychologue a expliqué un jour pourquoi
les hommes fantasmer sur les hôtesses de
l'air parce qu'inconsciemment elle pense
que non qu'elles sont libres comme l'air
à la fin donc vous alors vous attirer
par quel métier directrice des agences
bancaires pour les faire découvrir
j'aime bien les banques les directeurs
les agences non vraiment ça bossait
s'adoraient ah ouais ouais on est prêt
tout ça ça me fait fantasmer pas bien ça
fait flipper la puce a fait ça fait
passer mais non l'utile à l'agréable sac
à main voilà alors vous isabelle avec un
appareil militaire complet mais alors la
police montée bien monté
[Rires]
[Musique]
la menace est oui comme ça remonte les
champs elysées devant les chevaux sont
splendides les joues et ceux qui sont au
dessus aussi très bien benoît les
doucement on évite à la machette quel
métier vous attire chirurgien esthétique
très bien vous avez déjà eu recours à la
chirurgie esthétique
j'adore ça vous avez enfin j'adore ça
attention faut que ça soit pratiquée
avec parcimonie haruna effet vous l'avez
fait vous oui je les fais les films de
plastique mais bon là c'est pas le sujet
alors ça me ferait fantasmer parce que
la faute est alarmant brahim ferradj
omnium et je pense que c'est super sympa
et bien moi je restais voilà très bien
je dors chez toi les courses étaient
saines et vous dévoile à part moi je
rejoins nicholas et les hôtesses de
l'air aux as où sur un plus classique
mais j'ai eu une aventure avec une veste
dallaire mais dans l'avion va évidemment
dans l'avion quelle compagnie une
compagnie transavia c'est très sympa
très très simple combien de temps
laventure ben le bol
en fait dans le trip est en fait il ya
au dessus là dessus il ya une petit
petit petit teaser vient où on peut
dormir et c'est vraiment super spacieux
où j'avais sympathisé du coup j'avais
sympathisé longtemps il ya un certain
temps pour la circulation
ah bon c'est vrai qu'on appelle les gens
qui ont fait ça dans l'avion
non ce qui a porté le club dix milles à
l'est alors alors vous magali werder
alors moi mon fantasme et vinci mon mari
[Musique]
j'y viens moi-même harris un artisan il
est carrossier et je peux vous dire que
c'est un carrossier ou masse comme ça
avec ses belles mannequins des moitiés
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà voilà
[Rires]
c'est moi je me laissais de chautauqua
monsieur j'ai dit oui vous pouvez éviter
des deux côtés je suis bien chez entre
les deux ouais c'est bien parce que
c'est bien à l'été aux halles et moi
c'est lé prof d'espagnol mois depuis le
collège je suis amoureux de tout mais
prof d'espagnol arrêts elles ont le
charme l'accent est long tous je suis
fan d'ailleurs je fais un petit message
à madame autre est symétrique bezos la
salière bisou à la vôtre est malin votre
aide et barrages s'ils voulaient nous
nous appelons pas citer la grèce m
restez coutin merci beaucoup